seeing is how he's one of the most
popular fictional characters of all time
these days dressing up as spider-man is
relatively easy if your name is at all
costumes designed with his likeness or
soul just about everywhere be it's
simple Halloween costumes those plastic
helmet things you and your cousin would
wear except you'd let him have the iron
spider one because you want to be the
real Spidey because your cousin sucks
printed in sones anti suits and of
course the hyper accurate movie replicas
that cost two thousand dollars to even
look in the general direction of but
let's go back to a time before all this
fanfare and popularity to a time when
Spidey was still relatively new in the
eye of pop culture and his appearances
in real life were severely limited as a
huge fan of the character and a creator
of a decent number of Spidey costumes
myself I give you the most nation
hobbyist video topic ever a complete
history of non movie spider-man suits
also my friend Jacob is here alright
keep in mind by non movie suits we don't
necessarily mean no costumes produced or
used in movies we just mean like the
movies that came out in theaters the
ones everyone is seen already and made a
billion cosplays of no one cares about
those delicious shiny puffy body
stockings we're going old-school with
arguably the first spider-man suit ever
this one's a weird case because would
you believe it actually predates the
comic character is it that yellow one
Steve may or may not have been inspired
by why yes young Hackham this is um well
Steve kind of ripped it off and it took
like everyone fifty five years to notice
allegedly or maybe Jack Kirby did
allegedly or Stanley himself I don't
know the true origin of spider-man's
design is a little murky the more you
research into it much like the true
origin of a lot of Stan's stories the
rumor has it again rumor that Jack Kirby
worked for the Ben Cooper costume
company for a little while in the 50s
then in the 60s was tapped to be the
artist for spider-man he got about five
pages in and then Stan changed his mind
and asked Steve Ditko to draw it instead
Jack still got to do the cover of the
first issue though the sketchy part is
that the company behind this spider-man
costume was only 10 miles away from
Marvel's headquarters at the time
maybe Kirby designed this thing during
his suppose a tenure with Ben Cooper
maybe Steve Ditko saw it and it just
subconsciously stuck with him or maybe
it's just a big stupid coincidence
whatever the case let's stop talking
about it before someone Sue's Marvel or
Disney or whatever after being asked
about it in 2014 Steve Ditko just kind
of said no shut up you have no proof in
so many words I guess we'll never know
for sure how this factors into the
history but I still think including this
suit is worth it
now on to official suits produced by
marvel here's a shitty Halloween costume
from 1963 which was designed and
distributed by Ben Cooper costume
company huh would you believe this is
the first piece of licensed merchandise
by Marvel ever alleged we can't ask the
company itself because all of their
records were destroyed in a fire in 1989
which happened all the time the
pre-digital age I guess they're still
around though
even though they were bought out by
another company the Ben Cooper name
still being used you may have actually
spotted some of their work in spider-man
homecoming they've made the masks used
in the scenes where spider-man
encounters Ultimate Comics The Ultimates
this suit sucks man I know is the 60s
but they didn't even try why are their
webs on the blue parts why does he have
his name on his neck like a dog collar
in case the bad guys forgot this thing's
so off model they had to draw his
costume to look wrong in the ads just to
confuse those poor children of the time
who are now elderly now we can't exactly
cover every single Halloween costume
ever produced because there's like a
billion bootlegs that were made in a
time where it was a lot easier to
infringe on copyright laws so let's
shift our focus towards Spidey threads
that were officially commissioned and
used by Marvel of which there's a hey
wait a minute he's looked kind of
familiar logos are the same same
placement same shape based on the early
John Romita art but the eyes on Japanese
Spidey or squinty because joke and
Nicholas Hammond had this ugly drain
cover thing on his face but everything
else from the neck down is the Atari
commercial one used the same one
whitey wants us to vote my god Jacob
it's all don't jump ahead to the
democratic process spiderman take a look
at this one first it predates the 7u
Spidey and even The Electric Company one
besides the poor craftsmanship mouth
full and glue stains it's pretty
faithful to Steve Ditko's art I
especially like the addition of the web
wings and as far as I know it's the only
other official suit to have them until
Marvel Studios temporarily got their
hands back on Spidey it was the first
in-house spider-man costume made by
Marvel it was going to be used in the
Thanksgiving Parade of 64 or 65 but the
actors ran off with their cash and
didn't show up to use the suit since
they were paid in advance it's been
speculated that they got super drunk the
night before the parade and just didn't
even bother picking up the suits so they
handed the thing off to Roy Thomas a
co-creator of Wolverine and it appeared
at costume parties in comic book ads and
comic books themselves where he appeared
in cameo is wearing the thing they even
drew the webs to mimic the real-life
counterpart speaking of which god damn
there is some really strange problems
with how this one looks like it was made
although holding together well enough
for Roy to wear in these pictures it
looks like there's more glue in this
thing than there are seams it's got a
mouth hole for whatever reason and I
guess no one had figured out how to make
Peters two-way mirrored lenses yet the
designer also seemed to take fashion
advice from a gamma-irradiated nerd
pants are purple why also I've
colorblind so that's just confusing and
I can't even tell this costume was in
Roy Thomas's possession until 2017 when
he gave it over to silver and Bronze Age
comic memorabilia collector John Cimino
John Cimino is also the guy who
discovered the yellow spider-man costume
and brought that whole affair into the
public eye he was the one who mailed
Steve Ditko at one point time he owned
the first three spider-man costumes ever
created Roy and John later gave it away
to a private collector after showcasing
it at Big Apple Con in NYC so we'll
never if I can see this one again
man it's probably just sitting on a
mannequin in some rich nerds basement
somewhere it should be at the
Smithsonian next to the one from that
terrible musical shut up you watch the
whole thing with me on YouTube me at a
moment when it was over don't tell them
I liked it I need to be the guy who
hates everything anyway the first
spider-man suit created for use in TV
was for a little show called the
electric starring Morgan Freeman this in
my opinion was the best on-screen
spider-man costume until about 1981 this
thing was Steve's spider-man brought to
life it was used on the show from 1974
1977 over the course of 29 episodes it
was probably made by the costume
department of the show itself with
guidelines from Marvel this was by far
the easiest thing to research for in
this whole video since it's the only
thing with an actual Wikipedia page
during his appearances on the show he
basically just hung out with Morgan
Freeman that's about it the tables have
turned it's now Batman who's poached -
Lucius Fox
that's a deep cut if you want to know
more about this incarnation of
spider-man check out this episode of
comic tropes why doesn't he ask me to be
spider-man anymore is it because I
stopped wearing a cup - the recordings
after electric company Spidey fell into
obscurity it was time for spider-man to
make his big small screen debut the 1977
TV movie spider-man starring Nicholas
Hammond and his trademark bull cut and
his gun-toting clone
[Music]
and this is a god this was the first
suit that wasn't really based heavily on
Steve Ditko's designs but actually the
second big spidey artist genre meet a
senior and you can tell by the large
chest logo and the spaced out webs
silkscreen on to the suit and say it's a
dead ringer for his art safe for the
ugly giant ass web shooter and the
whatever it is they did for the eyes
someone should have been fired for this
good god it was a quaint little movie
followed by a quaint little series with
a quaint little costume it has a
horizontal zipper in the back that's
really hard to see it has some really
clean webbing and apparently no soles on
the feet because Nicky boy is having to
wear some red rain boots when he's got
to go outside out of all the Spidey
suits I've seen this one hits the best
balance between looking good on screen
but also seeming like something that
could realistically be made at home by
an impoverished nerd with no social life
and wonder why they decided he should
have winged eyeliner the later episodes
used a slightly better mask but it's
still distracting from how nice
everything else on the suit is while
this series was running in the state's
to--a a Japanese movie and TV studio
acquired the rights to do their own show
in 1978 which was batshit insane you
know spider-man mild-mannered nerd with
no money and girl troubles [ __ ] that see
this thing on his wrist this is soup Ida
man this ain't no web shooter he calls
down his transforming leopard Megazord
to fight giant monsters [ __ ] he's
spying on all the Asian girls we stand
he's an emissary from hell so vitamin
[Music]
might be thinking this looks a lot like
Power Rangers but that's because it is
this show inspired Super Sentai which
was then chopped up and re-edited with a
bunch of goofy white teenagers to be
Power Rangers at upon closer inspection
he's wearing the same suit the same
seems webs and logos the only different
thing is the mask which looks to have a
white fabric or mesh in the eyes as well
as differently shaped webs I can't tell
if it's intentional but the eyes are
kind of uneven on the mask so it looks
like he's kind of doing like a face of
you like he's raising one eyebrow what
does that even other than that it's all
just little chain just like the belt and
web-shooter
think the similarity and the costume
would be because they wanted some
synergy between brands right at least
that's what Jacob and I thought for a
little while until we noticed this same
suit is in the 1981 Atari commercial
just with a better mask and then again
in this weird ad where spider-man yells
at you for not registering to vote in
1992 the registration forms or
information on how to register your
local participating video stores have a
voice in your future register spider-man
and in the canceled canon film
spider-man movie that almost came out in
1985 which never saw the light of day
because the movie studio imploded
spider-man's wedding this comic cover
and event it's six flags standing next
to Stanley seven different times or help
every live event involving superhero
costumes for like 15 years it's all the
same suit
we love this particular commercial so
much that we started calling it voter
Spidey
so Jacob and I started asking some
questions about it when we noticed the
similarity you made it how many were
there why does the mask keep changing
but everything else looks the same
I imagine that Marvel just had a bloom
closet with like eight or nine of them
that they shipped around for events and
licensed projects but after a night of
investigating we finally came across a
name and some info these costumes had
been commissioned by a company named
Yves Brooks they used the same patterns
every time but they are the people who
ordered the suits altered the masks when
it came to different Spidey's with
different needs some of them had these
weird bug and shower drain looking
things sunglasses squinty white spandex
and asian white spandex
turns out Eve's Brooks hired a fella by
the name of Jesse Guerra to create the
pattern which they mass-produced and
sold the pretty much anyone who needed a
spider-man costume if you were working
on an official Marvel licensed
production or event this is where you'd
go to buy that suit for nearly two
decades sure other third party costumes
were probably sold but you can think of
this as the official seal of quality
these were other ones used for stuff
like official character meets at malls
and amusement parks no matter what they
ended up doing with the eyes which
colored fabric they used or who was
wearing it this suit was always just so
damn charming I think outside of the
cinematic costumes this one has to be my
favorite in all of its various forms for
professional spider-man performers this
costume was the default look for many
years these real-life superheroes all
worked with Marvel's personal appearance
department who negotiated scheduled and
facilitated all the events where Spidey
and other characters would be seen by
the adoring public
one such performer was a personal hero
of ours by the name of Steven barreto's
Broadus was an aspiring actor in Boston
University's theater program
he was ironically in classes with
Marissa Tomei and even did stage
performances with Michael Chiklis before
winding up working in serendipity 3
which is a restaurant in New York that
tons of big-name celebrities frequented
one day our co-worker at the restaurant
told him that he had a contact at Marvel
that was looking for an actor to play
spider-man at a Halloween parade coming
up this co-worker noticed that Steven
was both a trained performer and had the
perfect body type for it and got him
connected with Marvel thus began his
long career as a professional spider-man
he's been in advertisements live shows
hospital visits to sick kids and
conventions and hell he even took the
thing bungee jumping once
hey he's a great speech well when I get
to that point I'll give you them but
right now you might be dead long before
that here we go
[Music]
all in this Yves brookes classic suit
but like any good superhero costume
eventually the design had to change and
evolve a little bit to keep up with the
times sure a Spidey suit is generally
pretty timeless but over the years the
details have changed a lot so as it
turns out when that gets Todd room and
spider-man they had to update the
costume to stop small children from
bullying the performers whose mask
didn't look right by 1995 raw dose was
tired of the little Rugrats asking him
why his eyes weren't big enough because
all the current comics looked like this
verrano's notes that people were giving
him guff about the eyes for about five
years before any of the corporate suits
opted for a change
and Brad Oates was lucky enough to be
the first guy to test out and where the
next big section of this video
so this is where updating spider-man
costume should have ended just don't
change it not even for the movies this
one's [ __ ] perfect even when they
reboot the movies it should just be this
one again
no stupid additional black lines or long
pointy logo it's just the classic suit
rip straight from the comics he's very
passionate about it you see so this suit
was meant to bridge the gap between the
comic and live-action visions of Spidey
and I gotta agree it's pretty badass
Brad Oates was selected to be the one
lucky Spidey who got to go to the studio
of New York opera costume designer Betty
Williams she was according to Brad owes
a veteran of her industry and also kind
of grouchy but in like an endearing way
she designed the suit built the very
first one and then had him stripped down
and put it on in front of her in the
professional world it's okay to see each
other naked don't worry about it
Brad Oates noted that the IMS seem
different because he was having a harder
time seeing and later enough of his
fellow spider-man complained that the
suits went back to the original kind of
mesh Steven also noted that the padding
in the boots wasn't ideal as it could
allow the suit some hang time when
jumping and can make the shoes float
away from your feet and increase the
possibility of [ __ ] up your landing
and rolling an ankle
he said he'd prefer it if it had no
padding at all and I disagree with that
only on the grounds that you could step
on some broken glass at a convention
because people keep cosplaying as
Robocop villains mid death I mean what
do I even say about this one look at it
it's just spider-man it's got the eyes
the logos and
identical web pattern to the John Romita
senior art it's just the costume being
used on the corner box art in the comics
I don't know I guess it was just how
John was drawing spider-man after like
1978 why'd you sign your name twice John
you may remember seeing this one in such
obscure [ __ ] as Easter egg clip on
the x-men DVD the behind the scenes clip
of the ps1 game this cringy ass training
video where spider-man teaches a bunch
of children he kidnapped how to punch a
CGI venom into the side of a moving bus
web shooter commercials and Tony Hawk
one picture where Batman is like yelling
at spider-man but Stanley is like no
children don't fight I'm just gonna put
in that line that's that was perfect
when we know it from the best though is
Universal Studios in Orlando Florida
specifically the Marvel section of their
Islands of Adventure where he hangs out
with a few other live-action superheroes
he walks around the park says hi to
children takes pictures with fans signs
autographs does cool poses and he's even
got a whole ride the ride features such
memorable characters for the sinister
syndicate lineup such as Bob Bob one a
hydrant Hydra man and scream you know
the most popular spider-man villains
wait there's only five of them how much
is a syndicate that's not all so Jacob
goes this park like once a week so he's
the expert on all this stuff but in the
script I'm saying it for some reason
it's because I'm too lazy to write those
parts in the script myself for this
reason we've officially dubbed this
costume Universal spider-man we also
found out our research that there's a
slightly modified version of it in this
terrible spider-man musical called
spider-man rocks exclamation point they
used to play at the Universal Studios in
California
[Music]
[Applause]
for some reason California got all the
weird defect versions of all the
superhero costumes as for the musical
it's um it's kind of weird the songs
aren't original they're just covers and
the plot and imagery is really heavily
derivative of the movie
the suit has these rubber grips on the
hand so he can swing from a convenient
rope that always comes down from the
ceiling
speaking of musicals that are derivative
of the movie and have covers of
pre-existing music for the soundtrack
let's talk about the best thing in
existence again you've heard all the
memes some galaxies brains son of a
[ __ ] decided spider-man needed a
musical okay then Bono wrote all the
music then the great stuntman massacre
of 2010 happened it had a funny parody
sketch on Mad I'm Julie Taymor
Bono and I turned spider-man into a
Broadway musical that was you
nice going Brainiac and then everyone
collectively forgot about it it's very
yeah let's say unique somehow a lot of
the aesthetic and some of the story
choices remind me of the amazing
spider-man films
you know those hadn't even come out yet
music was kinda catchy shut up it's all
perfect which brings us to the costume
it's got all the hallmarks of the Raimi
suit big spiky logos silver webs pointy
eyes on some of the masks there's two
different kinds of masks for the show
with slightly different lenses we assume
the one with the bigger eyes was easier
to perform in for the actor much like
the one from the spider-man Rox musical
it has a faded edge that separates the
red and blue with a bend a dot texture I
like how the mask is a hood like the 80s
cartoon the mask actually seems to be
two different pieces so the hood is like
part of the actual suit and then the
face is more of a solid sturdy fabric to
kind of supplant a face shell or maybe
there is a facial in there somehow no
there's a muscle suit underneath it for
padding in case the actor smashes into
something while flying around in the air
like a true hero and also to get that
spider-man shape it was designed by a
Aiko Ashoka who passed away in 2012
meaning this production was one of the
last things she worked on
we love you Aiko thanks for helping keep
this exciting character we love elegant
and timeless Jacob even got a replica of
this suit Julie we have to close the
show it's too dangerous
are you kidding that's the great thing
about working with real superheroes
they're invulnerable I'm green
don't actually have any real powers run
the same time this show was running
Marvel made one more attempt at
capturing the live stage for their media
empire that didn't really work out lul
Marvel Universe live is exactly how it
sounds it's the Marvel Universe but live
the Spider Man costume here is a bit
more traditional but I couldn't help but
notice it bears a striking resemblance
to the turn off the dark suit even
though it was designed by someone named
Cynthia Nordstrom who I emailed and she
never replied back so thanks Cynthia I
guess for the time being we won't know
why these two suits are so similar or
why the back logo is just a recolored
front logo you but maybe she'll get back
to my email in ten months is that all of
them I think that's all of them
don't you recognize me to me you're just
another nut in a fighter suit you're a
dime a dozen in Hollywood no we gotta
talk about these shitty ones that we
don't have nostalgia for oh well
eventually they change the universal
suit for some reason [ __ ] [ __ ] so
[ __ ] for kid suit his ass
y'all like orange and gray that's the
color of this one these logos have no
character at all it's just a generic
ones you see on everything also the eyes
are like it's [ __ ] stupid for no
reason they can just still be round I
don't understand the scene work is
really sloppy around the masks of these
suits so it ends up making the webs look
horribly misshapen now some of you might
like the suit and that's fine this one
just feels cheaper to me than the
previous Universal spider-man costume
whoops
so these Disney parks have a heavily
derivative design of him even though
ironically they used to just have the
Andrew Garfield costume oh they even
changed the advertisements they did him
dirty I wonder if they'll go back to
using this one now I don't know this
stuff is so complicated it's weird
seeing this spider-man standing next to
the Avengers it's wrong God didn't
intend for this but hey that old one had
the comic logo on the back that's me
double cheap dump on my Thursday
afternoon Halla has the Sun is come out
we get someone who can do some better
poses up in the air nope ok alright well
this suit is actually designed by the
same guy who made the movie version of
MCU Spidey appreciate that they have
bigger logos and don't use the silly
black bands but it has this big ugly gap
on the shoulders now where the bands
should have gone what I really don't
like is this mask that has a seam in the
forehead that looks like a horn but I
think they fixed that later man whether
it's on a person or a mannequin the big
boots silver eyes and big head just make
this one look like an alien as opposed
to the times when he's supposed to look
like an alien that's all the official
ones I can think of Yves Brooks slash
voter Spidey seems to be pretty firmly
at a circulation but Universal Spidey is
still making appearances here and there
to this day even if it's not actually a
universal anymore the [ __ ] is Drusilla
spark Gold Coast's superhero weekend
what are these we have no idea how or
why or where this costume came from or
how to get our hands on one so if you
have any information please let us know
so we can [ __ ] stealing appropriate
social media links on screen in the
meantime though we've both decided to
take one step towards paying respect to
these two classics by getting our own
replicas custom made by zentai zone I
got both masks for the Eve's Brooke suit
and Jacob made the lenses for me and I'm
the best looking spider-man in Universal
Studios Florida we didn't live so far
away from each other that we could have
a pre-cool photo shoot with these this
is how you would actually talk we didn't
live so far away from each other we
could do a pretty cool photo shoot with
these which of these are your favorites
which one would you like to see more of
where can we get these two actual suits
please help us someone must have one in
a closet somewhere you don't want did we
miss any costumes we're talking about
when will they release the turn off the
dark dvbe
when will the video end actually I'm not
sure about
who's the guy in the milk commercial
just a quick reminder before you go that
I post my videos a day early on patreon
and give exclusive behind-the-scenes
content and patron exclusive videos
please consider becoming a patron it
really helps me out if you want a more
short-term way to support the channel
you can check out my merch and the links
in the description we have t-shirts
phone cases posters mugs pillows baby
onesies and so much more see you next
time hey you guys know that obnoxious
meme you've assuredly already typed in
the comments by now well guess what now
you can buy it on a shirt isn't that
cool go buy one right now please
[Music]
[Music]